you're in uncle drill yeah okay and you
have a big big family and we're just a
lot of people a lot of relatives yeah
and you had it so you had a family
screening of uncle drew they all came
what are you were supposed to be a
family screen this is my family all
showed up screening it was a screen it
and they end up getting an extra theater
could it was like kicking people out
that the I didn't know what he was doing
somebody wait it's a my family screening
I just got a lot of family they all
showed up because you look at this
picture they're all wearing larell
t-shirts and it looks like that looks
like a family screaming that's your
whole family right my whole family and
the crazy part is I didn't know they had
the t-shirt so until the end of the
movie so I just look like well get these
teachers made it and my family is a
bunch of church people so my uncle's
were pastor my aunt like she does
everything so they got they got a
hook-up at some like foundry Union
church picnic t-shirt making place and
they got to support you that shows a lot
of support yeah but if you know what's
funny I get it now but imagine being
like in high school and like you felt
bad for the kids who didn't have a lot
of family so my family would show up
with it that's gonna sound terrible but
where I grew up but I felt bad I have a
support and I know it sound terrible
until I was checked by another kid one
day late man you tripping because your
parents are here you are lucky I bought
my own graduation balloons I got my home
like damn that's starting oh here's my
question
you're I'm guessing that you have a
funny family I bet you there are a lot
of funny people in your family it's a
lot of funny people mock the funniest
person is my ID Joyce
god rest her soul was the funniest
person in the world to me like that's
what I was sitting next to at church
because she would talk about like
literally everybody like if a deacon
prayed to Allah here you go again he's
making remarks I always say is they'll
constantly and it wasn't like you know
at church people like either agree with
the pastor job right
like she would just make jokes like I
don't know make no sense this is opinion
so she would hear dude show up at
funerals and make jokes my auntie was so
I remember this is its cat out of it
it's a everything funny happens in my
life I bring my mom passed and my aunt
would be my choice we went to go weren't
casket shop were just that's a weird
thing we had to do I'm the oldest so I
had to go a mile go casket she'll
literally casket shop it's like a real
first of all people who own funeral
homes I'm not saying it weird but
they're just too comfortable with death
you know they do everything watch you do
everything like could you turn around
while look at the casket but anyway we
looking at the caskets and Mike jokingly
says oh I didn't get this one right here
and this really mean morbid funeral
things like oh no you need to order
yours because she was a really big lady
[Laughter]
she said it is just creepy way back in
the corner now you're doing is this
right you got they all do that - I don't
know why they're all like mr. burns on
The Simpsons they're all it's like they
glue their fingers together first thing
in the morning
hey buddy drive - yeah
that's how they pick things up sorry
about your I see you sister they shake
shake okay good we go like that
would you like to see the body again
you